لن نذهب الى لندن وتبقى معنا المتحدثه
باسم الحكومه البريطانيه روزي دياز مرحبا
بك روزي مضى عام على الحرب روزي كان هناك
تساؤل دائما لماذا كانت تتصدى بيانات
وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه والاستخبارات
البريطانيه المشهد الاعلامي في الحديث عن
المعلومات المتعلقه بهذه الحرب البعض يرى
ومن قبل خاصه من قبل روسيا ان هذا تحريض
على روسيا ببيانات غير دقيقه او صحيحه
شكرا لاستضافتكم الموضع هو واضح الان تخسر
روسيا الحرب ونستطيع ان نشوف هذا من خلال
مستويات خسائر روسيه على الارض هذه هي
الحرب ليست النجاس الذي تخيله بوتين بوتين
اعتقد انه
اوكرانيا في ثلاثه ايام فقط لكن كان على
خطا مع فخم قوه الاوكرانيين او وحده
من المجتمع الدولي
والان استعادت القوات الاوكرانيه اكثر من
نصف الارض
التي استولت روسيا منذ الغزو قبل السنه
بما في ذلك المواقع الاستراتيجيه المهمه
هذه هي الحرب تؤثر على البلدان عبر العالم
ليس فقط في اوروبا
والحرب تدمر الاقتصاد
الدولي
وكل هذا واضح موافقا للبيانات البريطانيه
ولكن هو السؤال كان لماذا تصدت
الاستخبارات البريطانيه هل كان هناك قرار
سياسي من بريطانيا ان تتصدر نشر البيانات
الخاصه بهذه الحرب من الناحيه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
قلنا نريد ان نشوف
الى الصراع لكن من الواضع انا بوتين لن
يتفاوض تعلم يعتقد ان عنده الخيرات
العسكريه
اذا سمحنا روسيا ان تستمر مع هذا الحرب
بالتاكيد هذا سيؤدي الى اكثر من العنف ضد
المدنيين
وتفاقم الازمه ازمه الطاقه والجدعه وتمديد
الانكماش الاقتصادي الدولي لهذا الان
بريطانيا وشركائنا الدوليين
يزيدون وطيره المساعده العسكريه
لدعم
واستمرار تقدم الاقراري على الارض
ولحد قدره روسيا لتساقف البنيه تحتيها
المعدنيه
المفكر البريطانيه والجهود الدبلوماسيه
ان تقلق تغيير حاسم في الصراعه هناك تصريح
منذ قليل لوزير خارجيه بريطانيا على شاشه
العربيه في لقاء مع الزميل طلال الحاج قال
في عباره واضحه ان هناك حق او الصين لديها
الحق في ان تقلق من تزايد الصراع في
اوكرانيا ما الذي تعنيه بريطانيا بهذا
الامر هل هي ترى ان الصين صاحبه حق مشروع
في هذه المخاوف وهذا يعني ان هناك انحياز
بريطاني لفكره طرح الصين للسلام
ام بريطانيا ستستمر ان تتابع
اراده الشعب الاوكراني كنا نريد ان نشوف
السلام
وبالتاكيد الاوكرانيين يريدون ان يشوفوا
هذا السلامه اكثر من اي اي شخص اخر
يجب على اوكرانيا
لتقرر
موقفها من حيث اي مفاوضات مع الصين مع
البلدان الاخر ليس للبلدان الاخرى الخارج
اوكرانيا لان اوكرانيا هي بلد
ديمقراطي ولذلك اوكرانيا
تحتاج الى ان تقرر
اجابه مختصره نعم ام لا روزي هل تعتقدين
ان خطط السلام الصينيه او تعتقد الحكومه
البريطانيه ان خطط السلام الصينيه هو خطوه
للامام لانهاء هذا الصراع ام لا نعم ام لا
ليس بسيط مثل هذا
كما قلت اوكرانيا هي بلدان ديمقراطيه
وليس بريطانيا او اي بلد اخر تستطيع ان
تقرر مستقبل اوكرانيا لها هذا اوكرانيا هي
هي في مقدمه اي مفاوضات واي قرارات حول
المستقبل ولكن الموقف البريطاني يمثل موقف
مبدئي من هذه المبادره جيده ام لا هذا هو
سؤالي
واعتقد ان موقفي وموقف الحكومه البريطانيه
هي هي هو واضح ان ندعم الصلاه
[موسيقى]
نحن جاهزين ان
نعتبر
الخطط المختلفه ولكن نركز على السلام في
اوكرانيا
وقلنا هذا منذ البدايه وفرن روسيا المسار
منذ البدايه وفي البدايه هذه هي الازمه
المتحدثه باسم الحكومه البريطانيه من لندن